e mezzo fa ho deciso di andare a vivere
da sola ed inizialmente le mie ricerche
si sono concentrate su milano ma dopo
aver visto i primi appartamenti ho
capito che amavo la mia brianza con il
suo verde con il calore delle persone
insomma ho deciso di ricercare casa nei
luoghi più vicine comuni alla mia
infanzia e la mia adolescenza
ora vivo a muggiò in una bifamiliare
dietro la mia vecchia scuola superiore
nelle vicinanze c'è un grosso parco che
ai primi accenni di primavera si riempie
di margherite
buonasera buonasera a tutti mi chiamo
evelyn a firma
ho 27 anni
sono nata in francia ma sono cresciuta
in italia
vivo in italia da quando un anno
e già sicuramente la maggior parte di
voi si sarebbe aspettato una ragazza
brianzolo doc
invece io sono nera o dei grandi occhi
un naso a patata delle labbra carnose e
dei capelli afro io mi sono sempre
definita italiana non ho mai avuto
problemi con i miei tratti con il colore
della mia pelle per l'università e per
il lavoro mi sono
trasferita o diciamo iniziato a
frequentare frequentemente milano e
milano riusciva a cogliere una parte di
me che forse nella mia vita a me era
sfuggita
insomma e b quella che si può definire
una crisi d'identità non solo diventata
pazza e nei schizofrenica ma
semplicemente le certezze di vent'anni
che si stavano sgretolando davanti
di fronte alla domanda io chi sono non
riuscivo ad avere una risposta completa
perché nell'essere italiana e si
ricordava il fatto di essere nera e
nell'essere ghanese mi si ricordava che
io ero nata in europa e che quando parlo
continua gesticolare
insomma lo sappiamo
iniziai delle riflessioni
delle meditazioni e arriva ad un punto
capì che non sarebbe mai esistita una
evelyn italiana al cento per cento ma
neanche una evelyn ghanese al cento per
cento
evelyn era un mix di culture un mix di
due paesi un mix tra italia e ghana
accettai finalmente questa duplice
identità
la bellezza di queste sfumature
essendo una ragazza i capelli diciamo
possiamo dire tra ragazze sono una cosa
su cui giochiamo molto decisi quindi che
finalmente visto che avevo deciso di
essere me stessa anche i miei capelli
dovevano essere loro stessi quindi ho
deciso di smettere con le serrature
chimiche e ho deciso di far crescere i
capelli naturalmente e ho scoperto dei
ricci ricchissimi afro dei capelli
bellissimi che mai avevo visto in vita
mia
insomma la prima cosa che ho fatto
andare è stata andare su internet e
cercare informazioni su come gestire
questi capelli questi nuovi capelli
perché per me erano qualcosa di
veramente nuovo
e ahimè tutte le informazioni che trovai
erano in tutte le lingue tranne che in
italiano in inter in francese in inglese
in americano ma in italiano non c'era
nulla nella lingua in cui io parlavo
quotidianamente tutti i giorni non c'era
assolutamente nulla e mi chiesi sono
forse l'eccezione sono l'unica ragazza
che in tutta italia ha deciso di
sfoggiare propri capelli
insomma ha deciso di fare qualcosa
perché io sono abituata un po così
quando c'è qualcosa che non va prendo in
mano la situazione
andai su facebook insomma tra ragazzi
facebook ha il mezzo più semplice e
facile per comunicare con e connettersi
e decise di aprire una pagina e la
nominai offro italian nappi girls afro
italian perché questo è un termine che a
mio parere esprimeva appieno la mia
duplice identità il mio essere italiana
e il mio essere ghanese nappi perché è
un termine afroamericano che descrive
due parole nacho ali np che in italiano
vuol dire felicemente al naturale perché
io con orgoglio sfoggio questi capelli e
gross perché all'inizio non pensavo che
questo mondo potesse coinvolgere anche
ragazzi ad oggi vi dico che è così
insomma questa pagina ha iniziato ad
aumentare in maniera molto velocemente
smentendo la mia il mio pensiero
iniziale di essere un'eccezione
sulla pagina si parlava di shampoo di
balsamo di maschere di come tenere
questi capelli morbidi perché sono molto
crespi e secondo me si stava
tralasciando un pezzo molto importante
quello che aveva fatto iniziare a me
queste ricerche che mi aveva spinto ad
aprire questa pagina ed era lato
identitario
a me piace scrivere però scrivo più per
me che per gli altri forse perché un po
mi vergogno però in questo caso dovevo
devo fare un passo avanti dovevo espormi
quindi decisi di scrivere un saggio e lo
nominai io chi sono in questo saggio
esprimevo appunto l'inizio della mia
confusione la presa di consapevolezza
fino ad arrivare a questa coscienza la
presa di coscienza di questa duplice
identità
questo saggio ha fatto un boom e la
pagina iniziato aumentare in maniera
molto vertiginosa e non c'erano più
solamente ragazze afro con questi
capelli
c'erano anche ragazze che si rivedevano
nella duplice identità
questo era il più il plus che la pagina
aveva bisogno di quella pagina aveva
bisogno
a sette mesi dall'apertura della pagina
una giornalista della ventisettesima ora
del corriere della sera e di regista
massimo coppola hanno bussato alla porta
di casa mia e mi hanno proposto di
girare un cortometraggio
io ero felicissima entusiasta perché a
gennaio mai avrei pensato di poter
girare un cortometraggio
è la cosa che più mi ha reso felice è
stato quando questo cortometraggio è
stato presentato a il tempo delle donne
in un appuntamento che è stato chiamato
chi sono le altre italiane
finalmente mi sentivo contemplata mi
sentivo presa in considerazione
finalmente in questa società c'era la
rappresentanza di evelyn della doppia
identità
insomma facebook è un luogo dove le
informazioni è difficile
raggrupparle tenerle in ordine
quindi ho deciso di creare un sito blog
una piattaforma che potesse appunto
rendere facile la ricerca di queste
informazioni
ho deciso di dominarlo knapp italia
nappi vi lascio immaginare già al perché
hanno spiegato prima è di taglia per
appunto dare il senso di appartenenza a
un collocamento geografico
ma una p taglia non parla solamente di
capelli parla anche della storia dei
capelli afro perché sia partiti da i
capelli naturali si è passati allo
stiraggio e adesso c'è questo movimento
che sta tornando indietro al naturale
parla delle storie di queste ragazze
perché per eveline è stata una presa di
coscienza identitaria ma per altre
ragazze può essere stato uno spunto
naturale un colpo di testa si parla
anche di nappi celebrities ci sono
giornalisti registi attori che anche
loro hanno deciso di tenere i loro
capelli al naturale
non si tralascia niente in questa pagina
esprime appieno ogni concetto che può
ruotare forse ha dei capelli che possono
sembrare così banali ma che banali non
sono per niente io un anno e mezzo fa
ero una semplice ragazza forse come
tanti di quelle che sono sedute qua in
platea era una studentessa una
receptionist e mai avrei pensato di
diventare una blogger diventare un
imprenditrice ad oggi diventare una
motivatrice di avere persone che mi
seguono e mi vedono magari come un
esempio di girare l'italia di incontrare
ragazze afro ragazze con origini latine
sudamericane mamme che hanno adottato
bambini con origini africane
insomma il suo ritrovate in un mondo che
inconsapevolmente o creato da sola
labitalia però a due messaggi molto
importanti che stasera voglio lasciarvi
il primo è quello della consapevolezza
la consap è la consapevolezza che in
questo paese in italia ci sono dei nuovi
italiani con dei tratti forse diversi
dall italiano doc italo ghanesi italo
ritrae i italo pakistani con gli occhi a
mandorla con le labbra carnose che alla
domanda qual è il tuo piatto preferito
vi risponderanno la lasagna o la pizza o
vi diranno che quando parto non si
mettono gli spaghetti in valigia
ecco questi sono anche loro italiani e
l'altro messaggio forse quello
universale che deve toccare più i nostri
cuori el'accettazione
accettarsi per quello che si è
per come si è di non inseguire
stereotipi di non inseguire figure che
magari media ci mandano ma di essere noi
stessi nella nostra interezza nella
nostra pienezza questo è il mio
messaggio